Siana I've got a game for you are you
ready yes okay we're gonna play a game I
call zoom around the room it's super
easy parents you can play at home with
your kids and others we're running out
of things to do at this point so I feel
you I'm going to will be given a random
word or phrase for my executive producer
which I do not know because I don't
cheat Jane Lynch
run and find an object to match that
like whatever they've said so the
further back to their camera with an
item gets the point
are you ready okay first clue is your
furry I just
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I recently purchased a peloton bike
sexier body behind as the sex we see you
okay one more
okay let's do it again one more
what is it it was a time but I'm gonna
say like points-wise was a tie but I'm
gonna say one cuz like the guitar thing
didn't even count I have nothing scared
so you win subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going